hi everyone sorry i'm late i have the
directional capabilities of a one piece
character so i got lost many times on my
way here well that's okay we're going to
get right into it my name is jeremiah
mabu and i'm here to talk to you about
functional programming
yes once my slides click brilliant it
worked so i'm a front-end developer
self-taught and a school taught systems
engineer from lagos nigeria so i'm a
long way from home but i'm actually
working in lithuania so it was like a
shorter flight
and um yeah you can find me online
anywhere at jemima boom so that's
twitter
linkedin medium github it's fun so let's
get into it what is functional
programming
basically in the world of programming we
have things called paradigms paradigms
are the way
code is written pretty much so
functional programming is a concept that
was invented in like
1954 and in this concept they basically
say you write code using pure functions
and
i'll elaborate on what pure functions
mean but first we have to look into what
the basics of functional programming are
so basic functional programming you have
pr functions how care functions work
think of it as like a mathematical
equation
in math two plus two is always four
right it doesn't matter if it's on the
mountain or
in the middle of the marianas trench two
plus two is always four and that's
pretty much the concept of a pure
function with a pr function whatever
input you give in should always return
the same output so if you have a
function and you return one input it
should always give you the same output
no matter how many times that function
is called or you know like a predictable
output so you can take it as functional
programming is predictable programming i
would say that's the basis
it also works with the values of um with
immutable values what that means is that
don't change your values pretty much
immutable values are values that aren't
modified in ways that you don't expect
so how that works is that every time you
let's say modify a value it doesn't
exactly change that value it just
creates a new instance of a changed
value
and then you have higher order functions
higher order functions are basically
functions that take in other functions
as arguments this is very common with
javascript and like
well in other languages too like python
and stuff when you have like your map
functions or your reduce functions it's
passing a function to a function as a
parameter because that function so many
times doesn't sound like a real word
anymore that's okay
and then finally we have minimal side
effects the principle of functional
programming like we said it's
predictable programming so that means
you want to minimize
unpredictability pretty much
and then
functional languages i'm going to skip
through this part because like i have
the javascript part and that's where my
main focus is but functional languages
these are languages that were created to
be functional by default so that means
you write them using all the principles
of functional languages you have
languages like haskell haska was created
to be purely functional you have clojure
and erlang and lis bliss was actually
the first functional language that was
invented so
that's fun for it and then you have
scala and then we have javascript i like
think of javascript as like this giant
monster because it just kind of does
anything and everything you can write
javascript functionally you can write it
with object-oriented programming or you
can write it as procedural so javascript
is not intended to be written any one
way
but it can be written in basically
javascript is more of like it's
prototype based you know so you can
write it however you want but in this
talk we're going to be looking at how to
write javascript in the functional way
well no we have to look at the benefits
first i forgot i had these slides so why
functional programming number one like
we said it's a predictable language so
it's less prone to error you know when
you have a database or you have like a
website or whatever and it's collecting
data you want to minimize how often you
get results you're not expecting you
know like
500 errors and stuff like that
and your code is more readable
functional languages are written in a
way that has predictable code so if you
have a function that says get user name
you expect that function to return the
username really we are different on the
password because now it's like
you call it username
and then it's easier to test and debug
because all your functions are
predictable it's easier to know where an
error is coming from so if i'm trying to
call data from a database and i'm
getting the wrong value for
let's say somebody's age i'm probably
just going to go to my function that's
called like get user age
and i know where my error is coming from
and finally it allows for easy
reusability of functions and variables
we see this a lot when you're writing
like react code when you have all your
components already predefined it's
easier to just like
impute them into other components
instead of like having to write new
things all over again
and finally no more this when i first
started learning javascript when i first
started learning react this was the bane
of my existence because you'd have to
write class components and i didn't get
why we had this but then if you want to
use this in a different class this then
becomes that because this would not work
if it's in another function like it it
baffled me to no end so yes that is my
favorite benefit of functional
programming we don't have to deal with
this anymore and we also have arrow
functions for the win this is no longer
a problem in our functions because this
in an arrow function always refers to
the function you're calling it in so
what that means is if i have nested
functions if i call this in function a
it's referring to function a but if i
call this in function b this refers to
function b
so easy simple
and great
let's get to the fun part functional
programming in javascript so we're going
to look at each of the basic concepts of
functional programming and see how we
can apply them to the javascript code
that we are writing
so javascript in itself like i said
earlier it does have
its functional parts so if we look at
react
originally when react was written using
class components we would have to define
it using the concept of object oriented
programming so we had to use this a lot
you know you had your this dot state and
you had this dot set state and if you
wanted to refer to a variable you'd also
have to use this and they would all have
to be destroyed in their constructors
with their supers and stuff but then
react hooks came out and react hooks are
based on the principle of functional
programming meaning we no longer have to
use this to refer to any variable we can
just use our hook and we can define our
real components as a function so that's
why you end up having things like const
my components extends react components
and then you can also define your state
variables just using constant you don't
have to refer to them using this because
everything is already inside
that functional
component
yes that makes sense i'm moving on
so basically the concept of functional
programming in javascript is that a web
app is just a bunch of functions stacked
on top of each other wearing a trench
coat so this is what i like to imagine
it looks like you just have your
components and your components and you
combine all of those to build your main
web application
so yes this is the basic structure of
most react web applications you have
your main application and then you just
call all your child components into it
this is the function this is the concept
of functional programming you want to
create tiny reusable functions that you
can then combine to build
it's like
a design system basically you create
tiny reasonable functions that are
easily defined and then you combine them
to build more complex functions and so
on and so forth until you have your
whole large application and it's great
so yes let's look at writing pure
functions in javascript so before we
look at pair functions we have to
understand what impure functions are so
let's take a look at this function it's
a simple piece of code we have our
variable a and we're setting it five we
define our function add and basically
what add does is that it adds b to a
so if i call add 6 it returns 11.
this is an npr function the reason this
is impure is because number one it
depends on a global variable you do not
want your functions to depend on
anything outside of the scope in which
you are calling that function because
what happens is
if
that variable is changed it affects your
function in a way you didn't intend for
it so here you can see we have we've
defined variable as5 and we've defined
our function add but now let's say let's
say this was a database actually let's
not even think of it as this simple
function let's say somewhere else you
were doing something with variable a
that happened to change it but now in
this it's some it's suddenly affecting
your add function in a way that you did
not intend this is one of those
unintended side effects we're talking
about so what happens here is that a is
modified and that affects your function
add
and then it's returning a different
value for the same imputes which is not
the predictable output we're looking for
so yeah you know avoid doing that
a pr function would be ensuring that
your function is only determined by the
parameters that you define in it what
this means is that we're defining all
our functions in the scope of the
function we're using we have our add
function and we have our parameters a
and b and we're returning a plus b this
function will always give you the same
values as long as you're passing the
same variables all the time so this is
how pure functions work you want to make
sure that it's only dependent on the
input you're passing in and it always
returns the output you're expecting
yeah that's like the easiest way to
define it really
so yeah it works on input only
and it returns same value for same
impute
so this is a fun little one so this
based on the previous definition we have
a random number function it's depending
only on the number parameter and it's
only returning a value we're expecting
would you say this function is a pure
function or not let me just say like
show of hand it's a pure function
ah thank you
show of hand it's an impure function
damn okay you're smart love that for you
basically the reason this function is an
impure function is because
in itself it does not return the same
value for the same input if i pass in
the same value four times it gives me a
different input four times that in
itself is not a pure function so it
catches like this because i mean it's
defined as a pure function but then it
doesn't fulfill all the requirements of
a pr function so
i mean to be fair you're hardly ever
going to call random numbers in your
database all you do actually when you
have stories that impute
that's beside the point the point is you
know it's not a pure function in itself
but then would you say this function is
a pure function
we have our maximum array function and
we're passing an array and it returns
the value that it applies to that array
would you say this is a pure function
damn y'all are nervous now is it an
impure function
i see we're very on defense yeah no this
one is a pure function because by
definition it does return the same value
for the same
impute that's passed into it so this is
also an example of using higher order
functions but we'll get to that later i
will not spoil the surprise for now
and then we have immutable values
immutable values are i feel like people
get really angry with javascript just
because javascript allows you change
values all the time it's like you define
a valuable as a variable as const when
they're later in the code you change it
and they're like if it's constantly
changing it but that's just javascript
and javascript is a beautiful language
that lets you do whatever you want which
is why i like it
so we have our um function here we've
defined wait i have a pointer that i
want to use
i love that
so we've defined our array here and we
have a function reverse array basically
what this function does is that
it reverses an array see that's the form
with functional programming very easy to
define component names and then we have
our new array function here so what
we're trying to do is that we're trying
to set new array as the reversed array
but then what ends up happening is that
this function
here reverses both arrays that we've
just defined which is weird right
because here it has nothing to do with
the global variable arr because what
we're passing is the parameter array
which is completely different but the
catch is because javascript is a
beautiful language it works the way it
works so if you pass in a variable
like an array or an object to a function
that carries out
let's say mutation on that value it's
going to affect the original array
regardless of whether you refer to the
global array or not
so that's why in javascript we end up
using
i keep on forgetting how these things
yeah original array is mutated great we
have a helpful little
arrow there
that's why in javascript we have things
called spread operators what happens to
spread operator is that it creates a new
instance of that variable that we've
defined in javascript when you're
working with arrays or objects you want
to always work with new instances and
you do not want to modify the
what's called the ordinary and i'm going
to use database example again and the
reason i keep using this is because we
were just working on a um
like this login screen that has to be
taken out of user data for like this
dashboard and you would not believe the
hell that it is when you start mutating
user values because you're trying to
let's say you're trying to get um
you're trying to get the first letter of
everyone's name because you want to sort
the arrays of basically well now because
somebody forgot to create a new instance
you end up having an array that's just
the first letter you end up having a
database that is just the first letter
of people's names it's not pretty so we
try to avoid doing that so that's why in
javascript we always create new
instances of things so with this one we
use a spread operator to create a new
instance and it's that spread operator
that we then reverse and what happens is
that our original array maintains its
original values and the new array has
the intended effects so that's kind of
how the principle of immutable values
works you want to always avoid mutating
the original values and only create new
instances which you then pass to the
variable that you want
yeah that's an easy definition
array is not mutated great
and then we come to the principle of
higher order functions so higher order
functions are basically passing
functions into other functions
let's take a look at how that one works
so here we have another fun little
function it's called the um you know we
have our defined variable and we have a
function double what we want to do with
this function is that we want to
multiply every item in that array so you
could create your for loop and then for
each item in the array just set
the array value times two
this is bad because
what you're doing here is that you're
literally reassigning every value in
that array so what you're going to end
up with is once again mutated values
and that brings us the concept of higher
order functions when you're passing a
function to another function
it creates its own new instance by
default
how that works is here instead of using
that for loop that we had previously we
replace our for loop with a map and then
we pass in this function x x is just the
item in the array which then returns x
times two the way the map works is that
it only affects the new instance of the
array that you're creating it does not
mutate your original value so the same
thing with maps with four h's with
reduces you always want to avoid
mutating original values and only
create new instances so yeah things like
maps
high order functions basically use a lot
of functional programming to avoid
having
what's the word i'm looking for
to avoid having mutated values
and that's it it's beautiful
function that takes a function as a
parameter does not change original
everything
and then minimizing side effects like we
mentioned earlier for the third time
functional programming is a predictable
language so when you're writing it you
want to avoid
having side effects that you were not
expecting so let's take a look at what a
side effect would be here we have our
function add and then we're returning a
plus b but then we're also
console.logging high and the c oslo a
console.log is a side effect because
what it's doing is that it's returning
something other than a value which are
functional um
no with your functions you only want to
return values you don't want to carry
out any other any other feature
that your function is not intended to do
because that's how you end up having
like spaghetti code and things changing
things are not meant to be changing
we also have
here we also have our array which says
high end dc oslo and then we return a
printed array problem with this one once
again is that it's mutating a global
variable join does mutate global
variables and this is something you're
trying to avoid you want to avoid
mutating global variables just because
you know it's bad
was that where i was going with this
yeah okay cool
applications of functional programming
in javascript that went so fast
we have react functional components
which we spoke about earlier in react
when you use end up using hooks and
stuff you do not have to define your
function your components as classes you
no longer have to have constructors or
supers you can just export a default
function and then you can call all your
variables the same way you'd expect
react hooks still work with the basis of
functional programming in that
you have a main function and it returns
what you expect it to return the catches
a lot of times in components we end up
defining a lot of other stuff inside
here that's all the handler methods for
our components but we'll talk about
about that later in what we call
necessary side effects
and then we also have react reducers if
you've worked with um
[Music]
state management properties in react you
end up using reducers a lot to um
just handle global states you know
reacts reducers also work with the
function of
with the principle of functional
programming in that for every case you
define you expect it to return a new
value another thing that's very
important with reacts reducers is that
you do not ever modify global states and
you realize how important the principle
of functional programming is when you
start working with global states because
if one functioning
functional
components
if one component is modifying states in
a way that it's not supposed to do it's
affecting the rest of your code meaning
that
well you can imagine the catastrophe
that that would be if one thing was
changing state and that thing was
calling it something you just had like
it be chaos so yes reacts reducers work
with the principle of functional
programming in that they always create
new instances of states and whatever
value they modify is just returned as a
new
state instance and not modifying the
original one
and then we also have functional
libraries for javascript so these are
libraries that allow you um
[Music]
write functional code in javascript it
kind of holds you to a higher standard
because there are people that prefer
javascript to be harder than it is i'm
not one of them but you know if that's
what you're into we do have functional
libraries that ensure that you write
javascript in a way that is
stricter i would say so
all of these ones i will be giving out
the slides later so if you're interested
in them you could always click the links
and then handling necessary side effects
like we said with most things in life it
never goes the ideal way in javascript
when you're working with web
applications or whatever side effects
are necessary it's impossible to avoid
console.logging things it's possible for
your functions to only return the things
that you intend so we're going to take a
look at how we can handle a few of these
necessary side effects
using javascript
the necessary side effect would be an
asynchronous request technically an
asynchronous request is not
pure it's not a pure function because
it's a function that it carries out a
value and then you have to wait for that
thing to be returned meaning other
things are happening while that thing is
happening
it's not predictable because you might
end up getting an error you did not
intend to get or it might end up
just doing things that asynchronous
functions do where
they just return unfulfilled promises
and stuff like that
we also have logging that's handling
things like logging errors or logging
data
console.log is a necessary side effect a
lot of times in javascript if you want
to
catch errors in a certain
part of the code basically or if you
want to test
and routing if you use react router and
you um
[Music]
you have to call the link in a separate
way than the intended way
i'm trying to think of a i had like a
use case for it from work but
it went away
but routing is also an accessory side
effects and then periodic updates this
is just things like
like recently we had to build this
countdown timer for black friday because
they wanted to count down to black
friday doing things like set timer where
you're constantly running a function
where it's not returning the same value
all the time or technically not defined
as a pr function but it's also an
accessory side effect because sometimes
you just need to constantly
um
update your page periodically
it is that
so one way of handling um necessary side
effects is to extract them if you have
like a api folder where you kind of
store all your
calls that you need to make to the
different
apis and stuff
you can put them in a separate folder
and define them as their own function so
technically what that function would do
would be to return its own response and
then you could import that into
somewhere else and then return that
function into somewhere else so it's
kind of like
extracting non-functional code to make
it work as functional
if that makes sense anyway basically you
end up using this a lot of times in
real life scenarios just because the
more
code you write for a application the
more bulky your system gets and why you
need to extract things more into folders
and stuff
and then function
using middleware functions if you end up
working with um react reducers like we
said reducers do not take any
side effects so you can't do anything
else to reduce or apart from modifying
the state you're passing into it but
then what happens if you need to
validate a user entry from state so
let's say you have your user logging
details and that's the state value so
you have user name and you have password
as your state values but now before you
store those values you need to validate
them for example you need to make sure
user name only contains string i need to
make sure password fulfills the password
requirements where it has a capital
letter and it has a symbol in it
react reducers would not allow you do
any of that because all of those things
count as side effects all reactor
reducer cares about is
updating states that's where we include
the principle of middleware functions
and there are libraries that allow you
to do this by yourself so how middleware
functions work basically is that they
take the store the store is where your
global state value is stored and then
they call in next function that next
function is where your side effects
would be stored so in my next function i
would decide what what um
side effect i want to carry out on the
states basically before it's passed and
then they pass that value to the action
so middlewares are basically just like
um
you know like a small little box where
all the magic happens before the actual
action is passed to the reducer that's
kind of how i like to think about it
um
side effects dispatch modified action
yeah
and um
that was a very quick but yeah that is
all i have for you guys today
if you i feel in my head this thing took
so much longer because it's like 70
slides and i was like yeah that'll be
well over one hour i was wrong so here
we are if you want the links to the
slides you can find them on my website
gmailmap.com slash talk slash functional
hyphen programming and also if you want
a list of further resources you can read
up on um i
found a few online i really like this
talk by anjana vakil she's actually the
reason i wanted to learn functional
programming in javascript so if you come
across that i would definitely recommend
checking it out there's also released
some really great articles by ali
spittle and max million on functional
programming and exploring the different
types of programming paradigms and then
some with just related to javascript and
functional programming
that's all quick talk love that for me
thank you very much i will be taking um
[Music]
i'll be taking some questions now if
anyone has any questions
if there are no questions i will be
referring some of my previous questions
from the last time i did this talk
because i always come prepared
so i think last time i did this talk
someone did ask how
practical is it to use functional
programming in like the real life
because the reason a lot of developers a
lot of javascript developers in
particular do not like using functional
programming is because
it's a good way of writing code but it's
also a longer way of writing code
sometimes you don't want to have to
define three different functions when
you can just cram everything into one
function you know you're on a deadline
now things are taking a while just come
everything one function if it has a side
effect so be it and what i'd like to say
with that is that
it is practical in a real life situation
in the same way how important your code
base looks to you is practical because
while it may be faster to just write
javascript in the javascript way
it gets unreadable at a point if you are
calling multiple instances of something
or if
if you just have like one giant file
where all your code is just compiled and
then you have an error and then you have
stack console
every single time i have to console.log
four different values in one function
because i'm not quite sure where my
error is where my error is coming from
i'm like curse you object-oriented
programming with functional programming
you kind of avoid doing that so that's
what i would say i would say
it's like it takes more time and it is
kind of annoying
but it's also kind of good because it
has its benefits so that would be the
answer to that question i asked myself
any other questions from somebody that's
not me this time
yes thank you very much i was just
wondering uh uh you mentioned uh like
functional libraries like yeah around
and stuff do you tend to
do
you tend to use that in like front end
with typescript because i've noticed
it's uh
like
it's a it's uh the support for
typescript it's gonna be not so great
and and like in my company they tend to
want us to kind of
just do
you know script or type without
oh
good question let me think about that i
do know that when we used we do use
typescript but we only use it on one
project just because typescript is
freaking annoying
it's
it's good it's great you should always
define your type strongly you know you
want to ensure that you're getting data
in the way you intend to get it
but
yeah no
with minimizing it using other libraries
i don't know actually just because like
i don't use like
yeah i don't use functional libraries
myself yeah like i said they're
i like javascript you know in the messy
way it is so
but if you all are interested that's why
i have them for you guys not for me
all right
any other questions
thank you
in the project i'm at now there's these
async functions
and the way it's set up now it's not
returning a partner so i sort of have to
list into a mistake
okay do you have a good actor can you do
that
yeah so actually what we
you know what i have a freak me why did
i do that i have a talk on middleware
stuff and i did include a function there
just on using so what we use is we use
epics in combat in combination with
redux and
we've worked with saga as well so
basically how it works is that epics
uses observables
so
it kind of detects itself when the
promise is returned and then it carries
out the updating states so let me see if
i can find that real quick for you
how do i escape
look at that two talks for the price of
one aren't you lucky
uh
yeah my screen does not want me to leave
how do i
wait
who knows the key for like exiting full
screen with max is it f11
is it no
i'm pressing exit yes
i am calm
shift command up
yeah that didn't work
i'm stuck on my screen i will define it
with my head so
yeah we use ethics observables and how
the observables work basically is that
you pass enough
it's kind of like with promise.all
you're kind of just passing a function
to the observable and it waits until all
the promises have been resolved and then
it will return the value so that's kind
of for me that's the easiest way for
detecting
um
for handling asynchronous premises so
case in point i was i'm working on this
this project we're working on at work we
need to call a we need to use the google
timezone api to return the time zone for
a particular location that a user is
passing so what we do is that we get the
location
and then we have to map that location
with the time zone api so mapping
mapping itself cannot be asynchronous
function because it defeats like i said
mapping is kind of intended to be um
functional because it's a high order
function so we cannot use an
asynchronous function with maps so what
we end up doing is that we end up using
a promise.o
and then passing that value into the map
so what we do is like you await your
promise.o and then you call the you call
your map function and then you call your
async function which is the defined
asynchronous function it's you end up
using like four awaits keywords and the
one thing but yeah that is the catch
with
handling necessary side effects you know
so i would recommend observables or
just trying to cut your promises you
know catch those little promises
all right i've gotten two questions
which is very good but i'm willing to
take more because i'm generous anybody
else
i'm here for a while so you guys come on
it's just gonna be awkward if i'm
standing on stage actually let me see
how many
yeah like
a lot of minutes
any other questions i am willing to take
questions outside of functional
programming as well you can ask me stuff
about javascript and i will do my best
no no
going once
going twice
i have a question
[Music]
when i use javascript it's there's often
been a lot of weird things that surprise
me
do you have any good resources for
learning those weird things
ah javascript
yes javascript is unpredictable in the
best of ways you know kind of how
sometimes things are false but then
sometimes they're true but not all false
things are equal to other false things
you know like an empty array is not
technically no but it could be undefined
and then you're like
like null is not undefined
what does that even anyway
i too have a lot of problems with
javascript um
what would i recommend for understanding
the weirdness that is javascript huh
i think honestly i just kind of accepted
it you know i was just like sometimes
things are just things like that but
that's a bad answer let me look
something up for you
uh huh
have i come across any phone articles on
understanding
honestly most of it's just a lot of
twitter threads of people complaining
about how i'm doing javascript is i can
i literally cannot think of anything
that's actually helpful
but if i do i will include it in these
slides and you will have access to it
how does that sound or you can find me
after and i'll look something up on my
phone right now i'll let you know
you don't know javascript that is a fun
one yeah i went like four pages into
that one and i was like you're right i
don't know js so i closed it but if you
want to read it you should
i also write javascript for dummies
because i have a thing for books that
insult me apparently so maybe you could
check that out
as well
all right i've gotten three questions if
there are no more i will pack up that's
a lie i'm staying here so i get more
yeah
functional factors a lot and what are
the benefits of the ones you use like
which ones do you use and what are the
benefits
yeah so with functional patterns with at
work we work with um atomic design and
we try to always stick with like at
least using pure functions so how that
works is that we break our components
into atoms so what we would have is that
we would have a button component button
components always return just the button
so in that button component you can
define all the
variants of a button that you would like
you know so you could have primary
button secondary button you could pass
in any parameter and then it would
always return what you expect and then
from atoms we go to organisms organisms
combine atoms so let's say i have a
butting atom and i have a label atom
and i have an impute atom in an organism
i could have an impute field organism
which would then take an impute on the
label and then from an organism you go
into a molecule where you end up
combining organisms
i hate when i say too many words but you
understand what i mean i hope you go
from molecules finally to
templates i want to say so basically how
we work is that we build on tiny
functions and we use those tiny
functions to build larger functions
because you're working with tiny
functions you always want to make sure
that all your tiny functions are
predictable so that when you use them in
your larger functions it avoids having
side effects you don't intend so yeah
that kind of pattern we tend to use pure
functions more the things like
minimizing side effects like we've said
side effects are necessary in javascript
so we just try to handle them as best
but yeah we're not purely functional in
that aspect
so that is that
i got four questions i'm on a roll let's
make it an even five huh i'm greedy yes
i know i said i'd stop at two but i'm
hoping for five now
i
have i have time we have lots of time
yeah
i'm not used to javascript sorry
is there a way to do that
oh yeah in javascript we just use
catches so how that works is if you have
your um let's say you're fetching a
value
from a database you can you have your
try and your catch functions so with try
you just
if the function is okay
then pass the response if it's wrong
catch that error and then return that
error to something else so with our
projects we use like toasts like those
tiny little notifications that pop up so
if we catch any errors then we just pass
them
to the toast value and then the
computer restarted weird
so we passed the error to the toast
value and then it's
that's kind of how we catch it is that
similar to what you're doing haskell
how do you do it in oscar
i don't know what that is what's a
monastery
is that monarchs like m-o-n-a-d
you learn something new every day all
right great i've not used haskell i feel
like clearly i don't look like the
camera pressing that right house girl my
brain does not work that way so
but thank you that was a good question
all right i got five questions and my
laptop shuts itself down so even it is
tired of me so i'm just gonna close this
now if you guys do have any other
questions like i said you could ask me
on my website jumaimbo.com or on twitter
at jamaimabu and you know i'd love to
chat so thank you so much for listening
even though i went off topic so many
times just so many times
but thank you guys very much and enjoy
the rest of the conference
[Applause]
you